It work.
So I've been wanting to teach river how to cut up her own fruit
because she's always, like,
wanting to cook and do stuff with me.
But I'm not quite ready. Just to let you free with this.
Right. That perfect slice on the tops off of this.
So I can easily just slice some tops off
and then let her have at it with the rest of the fruit.
You like, kind of green fruit.
Is this mine? Obviously,
I am still teaching her knife safety
and teaching her how to cut strawberries.
But with this, I can just cut the tops off and just.
Just walk away and let her have at it.
See how you slice them all up?
Wow. Is that hard to push down, or is it pretty easy?
Pretty easy. Pretty easy.
Easy for you with strawberries.
But it's not sharp for your fingers, huh?
No, no. Perfect.
Thirty six dollars and sixteen cents for two of them,
and you get two in the pack.
Two would be perfect to slice, um,
vegetables or fruit at the same time.
You can definitely use this with strawberries,
eggs, any kind of fruit.
Probably grapes.
Is available now on my TikTok shop, on my TikTok showcase.
Go ahead and click on the link below to get yours today.